so an appearance that i did on fox
television
last week um has been
blown up and uh carved up to
the use of left wing crazies and uh
my twitter feed is full of things like
this prince sleeper says
uh dave ramsey you're actually a piece
of
um blank lm laugh
my off okay and so basically i've got a
bunch of juvenile delinquents all over
my uh twitter left wingers because
i've got about two national on the
national scene i've got about two on the
local scene i've got about three
more uh left wing
uber progressive socialist reporters
who detest everything i do
and do their best to write up an article
showing that i'm a knuckle dragging
primitive idiot
so but all of this is because i said i
hate the stimulus package because if
1600
1400 600 changes your life you're
already screwed
you don't have a life and that means
that dave ramsey is a
an old white man that hates everybody
and
dave ramsey is um
a uh a piece of blank and uh
uh all because i told some snowflakes
they couldn't get some free money or
shouldn't get
some free money from the government
so let's go and walk through why i would
say something like that is it because
i'm
really mean and angry and hate poor
people absolutely not it's absolutely
ridiculous
on the contrary i've spent my life
helping people get out of debt and
become wealthy and have helped more
people get out of debt and become
wealthy probably than anybody living on
the planet right now
we've got 20 million people listening to
this show and podcast on a daily basis i
mean
add it up so let's talk about
why i would say that because i am at war
with anything that is going to keep you
with anything or anyone
that is going to keep you the listener
you the reader from living
in abundance i want you to win
financially
and i am sure after 30 years of teaching
this that personal finances 80
behavior and 20 head knowledge
and so how you behave is
most of why you are able to build a life
of abundance starting from nothing which
i have done
twice i started from nothing became a
millionaire by the time i was 28
lost everything because i was stupid and
then i moved
on and did it again in spades
so the idea
that your behaviors come from your
beliefs
is a big deal what you believe
about life causes you to behave in a
certain way
if you believe that if you step on that
ice and it cracks you're gonna fall
through
and drown in the in the pond you're not
gonna step on the ice what you believe
affects your behaviors it causes your
behaviors all of your behaviors come
from your beliefs
so when you believe something that is
false that is a lie
i am especially when it comes to live
you're living your life in abundance i'm
going to call it out
now if you believe that the government
giving you six hundred dollars is going
to cause you to
live in abundance that's ridiculous
but if you believe that then that gives
you permission to sit on your thumb
and not go about taking responsibility
for your own life
now i don't mind if you take the six
hundred dollars i'm not mad about that
what i am mad about is this idea that
it's gonna fix your life it is not gonna
fix your life you are going to fix your
life
and until you take personal
responsibility for your life
you're screwed
is there systemic problems with wealth
inequality
not as much as the extreme left thinks
because they think it's so
systemic and so overwhelming that you
will not be able to win
until wealth is redistributed that has
never been proven to be true
not in the history of mankind
but if you believe that there are
systemic
problems that keep the little man from
getting ahead then you will not
take responsibility for your life and go
win and that makes me angry
and so chris hogan and ramsey solutions
did a book called everyday millionaires
where we did the largest study of
millionaires showing that 93
of america's millionaires started from
nothing and received nothing too close
to nothing
or received money after they were
already millionaires they did not become
millionaires mathematically in the
largest airtight study ever done
of millionaires in north america they
did not become millionaires
mathematically because of an inheritance
so if you believe that the only way to
become wealthy is to inherit money
therefore you don't take personal
responsibility for your life
i'm gonna yell at that for your own good
i'm already a multi-millionaire i'm okay
i don't i'm not a grifter i don't need
your money
don't buy my stuff if you're mad about
this it's fine with me
don't listen to the show if you're mad
about this it's fine with me
just don't sign up for stuff i'm fine
with that but
everything you're going to get from the
ramsey organization is going to be about
you being a grown up and taking personal
responsibility for your life
if you're waiting on the union if you're
waiting on the government
if you're waiting on your big company if
you're waiting on
anything other than you the person in
your mirror to take responsibility
personal responsibility for your future
you are going to fail
you're going to fail because all of
those things are going to let you down
if you believe that the only way to
become wealthy
is to inherit it then you believe a lie
and your belief in that lie causes you
to shut down and not stand up
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home and that pisses me off because
it keeps you from winning
it keeps you from winning if you believe
that the government
declaring a fifteen dollar minimum wage
is going to change your life
very few people get rich on fifteen
dollars an hour
you're gonna have to do better than that
sweet cake
suck it up buttercup you got to get up
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home hustle and grind
it is your personal responsibility to go
create a life of abundance
and when you think that someone else is
going to cause you to become successful
that is the moment you have signed your
death warrant to the success parade
you're not going to be in it
and so the lefties saying the government
is here to save you
is a lie now if they send you some money
take it it's one of the few good things
they're ever going to do for you
that's fine but you sitting on your
thumb
because you think the government is
going to fix your life
you are screwed you are worshiping a god
that doesn't exist he's a dead god he's
called government as your provider
he is not your provider she is not your
provider
they don't have the capacity and they
can't do it and they won't do it
you run out of other people's money when
you believe in socialism
you are responsible for you darling and
i want to lead you into abundance from
wherever you are
but believing bullcrap is not going to
get you there